رائحتها كارهه جدا لدرجه ان هذه الحيوانات
الاليفه لا يمكنها تحملها يصفها البعض
بانها تشبه رائحه البيض الفاسد او رائحه
جيفه حيوان نافق شكلها غريب وكانها بيضه
تنين اسطوري ورغم كل ذلك فان مذاقها حلو
ولذيذ ويلقبها عشاقها بملكه الفواكه انها
فاكهه دوريان الاستوائيه
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
بمجرد فتحها او تقطيعها تطلق فاكهه دوريان
رائحه كريهه للغايه لدرجه انه تم منعها في
الفنادق ووسائل النقل العامه والمطارات في
كثير من دول العالم وخلال نقلها وتخزينها
يتم التعامل معها بحذر بطريقه مشابهه
للتعامل مع المواد الخطيره او السم عام
2018 تم اجراء اكثر من 500 طالب ومحاضر من
معهد مالبون الملكي للتكنولوجيا في
استراليا بسبب ما اعتقد وقتها انه تسرب
للغاز ليتبين لاحقا ان احدهم كان يخبئ حبه
من فاكهه الدوريان في خزانته ومؤخرا تسببت
تلك الفاكهه بهبوط اضطراري لطائره تابعه
للخطوط الجويه التركيه كانت اقلعت من
اسطنبول باتجاه برشلونه حيث انطلقت
تحضيرات اجهزه الاستشعار في قسم الشحن
بالطائره ولد ملاحظه الطاقم الكريهه
المنتشره قرر الكابتن العوده الى مطار
اسطنبول بعد ان كان قد وصل الى الاجواء
البلغاريه السر وراء رائحه الدوريان
الكريهه واحتوائها على نسبه عاليه لانزيم
معروف باسمي ميثيونين جمالياز الذي ينظم
مركبات الرائحه ورغم ان اغلب الفواكه
الاخرى لديها نسخه واحده او اثنتان من ذلك
الانزيم الا ان ثمره الدوريان لديها اربع
نسخ وهو ما يفسر رائحتها القويه
فذلك قد يجعلكم تنفرون من الدريان لكن من
جربها ربما يكون له راي مختلف فخلف كل تلك
الرائحه الكريهه تخبئ الدريان مذاقا لذيذا
وحلوا يوصف مذاقها بانه اشبه بمذاق
الكاسترد وهو مزيج من الكراميل والفانيليا
كما ان لها ملمسا ناعما من الداخل
[موسيقى]
بشكل خاص في دول جنوب شرق اسيا التي تشمل
ماليزيا وتايلاندا والفلبين واندونيسيا
وموطنها الاصلي جزيره بورينيو وسومترا
الاندونيسيتان حيث ينبت هناك اكثر من 30
نوعا منها لكن تسعه انواع فقط صالحه للاكل
اما اسم دونيان فياتي في الاصل من الكلمات
الماليزيه دوري التي تعني شوكه غذائيا
تعتبر الدوريان غنيه بالحديد والبوتاسيوم
وهي مفيده للعضلات وصحه الجلد وضغط الدم
علاوه على ذلك تحتوي تلك الفاكهه على
الياف مفيده لصحه الامعاء شاركونا ارائكم
هل لديكم الفضول لتجربه فاكهه دوريان